[Music]
on this saturday night
the health risks facing the u.s
president
donald trump's covid19 checkup the
president received
a special antibody therapy directed
against the coronavirus
his wife his inner circle and his
campaign team
infected could this have an impact on
the american election
loosening cross-border travel
restrictions i shed tears every day
there but as of yesterday i think i've
turned the corner the elation for
families looking to reunite
with loved ones plus
justice for joyce the outrage over the
treatment of an indigenous woman
as she lay dying and the protector of
the environment who made a mark on
parliament
the first elected green member of
parliament in canadian history
where do the greens go from here
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with the u.s
president's health donald trump is said
to be working from his hospital bed at
walter reed military medical center
the president tested positive for
covid19 so did his wife
so did key figures in his inner circle
and on his campaign team
it's still not clear where and when
trump contracted the virus
but as jennifer johnson reports the
focus tonight is on the risks he faces
with a disease he played down at the
beginning of the pandemic
doctors say u.s president donald trump
is doing well at walter reed national
military medical center
while battling covet 19. his doctor says
the president is undergoing a
five-day course of the experimental
treatment from desere
at this time the team and i are
extremely happy with the progress the
president has made
thursday he had a mild cough and some
nasal congestion and fatigue
all of which are now resolving and
improving dr conley painted an
optimistic picture contradicting white
house chief of staff mark meadows
who told reporters the president's
vitals over the last 24 hours were
concerning
and the next 48 hours will be critical
multiple reports say the president
needed supplemental oxygen while still
at the white house
the president tweeted i'm feeling well
but doctors say his age
74 and being slightly overweight make
him more at risk
we have monitored his cardiac function
his
kidney function his lower function all
of those are
normal the president and first lady are
among several people who have contracted
the virus after attending the ceremony
announcing judge amy coney bear its
nomination to the u.s supreme court
others include former counselor to the
president kellyanne conway
and republican senators mike lee and tom
tillis
i think the the network of people who
are possibly infected and carrying this
virus are just it's almost unlimited
trump campaign manager bill stephen and
former new jersey governor chris
christie have also tested positive
they were part of a small team that
prepped president trump for his first
debate
against democratic candidate joe biden
here i put a mask on it
you know when i think i need it in the
audience members of the president's
family refused to wear masks
violating an ohio mandate but sticking
to a common theme for the trumps and
members of his administration
throughout the pandemic democratic
candidate joe biden has tested negatives
so far
copen 19 now becoming even more of a
centerpiece of his campaign
we need to take the science of fighting
this disease seriously
if we're going to save lives doctors
won't say how long the president will
stay in the hospital
vice president mike pence remains virus
free and continues to campaign while the
president cannot
adding more chaos to a presidential
election just over a month away
jennifer johnson global news washington
our washington bureau chief jackson
prescott is here now to talk about the
implications of the campaign with donald
trump
in hospital and exactly one month until
the election jackson
robin there are a few critical things to
remember as both campaigns try and press
ahead at full speed
one is that voting is already well
underway millions of americans have
already cast ballots in person
or by mail and number two is the
pandemic is the one
issue president trump is desperate to
avoid talking about
now he can't it is the issue in this
campaign
now the trump campaign says the
president has obviously suspended all
in-person campaigning
but the vice president and three of his
children are set to hit the campaign
trail
for in-person events this week meanwhile
former vice president joe biden is
pressing ahead
as close to normal as possible we should
point out he has
pulled all of his negative campaign ads
from the airwaves out of respect
for the president really though these
are critical final days of the campaign
and robin they're especially critical
for president trump who is well behind
biden in the polls right now but what
happens if one or both of the candidates
becomes too ill to finish the campaign
well this is where the electoral college
which is often maligned might actually
come into play and here's a hypothetical
for you
if one or more of the candidates somehow
becomes incapacitated between now and
election day
the electoral college could actually
step in and appoint a candidate to be
chosen by the electors
the electors would be instructed by
their party national committees
to vote for x instead of president trump
or if something happened to
uh former vice president biden a vote
for y
instead of biden so the electors don't
even meet
until early december and then they
forward their votes to congress and
congress
counts them and makes it official in
early january
the inauguration is january 20th so our
system draws this out and actually makes
it easier to adjust
if something terrible happens
okay jackson what about the remaining
presidential debates
will they continue
yeah this is the big question in all
this and it really depends on how
president trump's recovery goes
we know that the commission on
presidential debates is also looking at
changes for any of the upcoming events
and the big one would be requiring all
audience members to keep their face
masks on
at all times and this comes after
several of trump's family members
refused to wear masks during the last
debate the first vice presidential
debate between kamala harris
and mike pence is scheduled for this
week we already know that the two
candidates have been moved further apart
on stage
but really robin it's a big open-ended
question as to
if or how any of these events can go
forward right now
our washington bureau chief jackson
proskow thanks for that analysis
turning now to the situation in this
country quebec
is once again seeing a major spike in
cases
in the last 24 hours 1107 people in the
province
tested positive for the virus that's the
highest one-day total in
any province or territory since the
pandemic began
in ontario more than 650 new cases were
added today
there have been more than 164 000
confirmed cases of covid19 across canada
since the beginning of this health
crisis the pandemic has separated
thousands of canadians from loved ones
living in different countries
but tonight they finally have something
to celebrate
the canadian government is allowing more
exemptions for the border closures
and as abigail beeman explains it
includes extended families
couples and international students i
woke up this morning
actually feeling excited for the first
time
in probably you know six to eight months
seeing each other on screen has been the
reality for sarah campbell and jacob
taylor since february
taylor is in the uk and wasn't allowed
to visit canada
but come october 8 the government is
changing the rules
allowing them to reunite we'll include
people in
an exclusive long-term relationship
and their dependent children as well as
non-dependent children
grandchildren siblings and grandparents
being separated from your partner in a
pandemic is tough enough
the cancer issue has been really hard
sort of being sat here because i'm
always sat here on the sideline
sarah had to undergo surgery for thyroid
cancer alone
and radiation is coming up in november
all you need
and all you want is literally just to
hold
your partner's hand and just to be there
the physical presence
it means so much and you know having
gone through
um that surgery without him
i just know it's going to be so much
better with him
like anyone else coming to canada jacob
must quarantine for 14 days
the couple plans to get married his
first day free
but the government also announced some
quarantine exemptions
on compassionate grounds these
situations could include
being with someone you love to say
goodbye at the end of their lives
or attending a funeral or end
end-of-life ceremony
this victory you know is uh is a proper
legacy for
my wife and the struggles that we had
a legacy for donna mccall because the
news comes too late
the woman who spent decades caring for
others as a nurse
died in august without her children by
her side they live in the u.s
mccall fought to change the rules for
others ever since
the group faces for advocacy believes
this could help
thousands we hope that the people of
canada
when they hear this news understand that
we don't want to get our mothers sick
we don't want to bring coven to our
families we're going to do this safely
newly widowed mccall says he's alone in
town
and hopes his brothers in chicago will
now be able to visit too
i grieve every day that's for sure there
i shed tears every day there but as of
yesterday i think i've turned the corner
because
this is these are tears of happiness now
abigail beeman global news ottawa
bill c4 has received royalists sent it's
a new benefit for workers and others who
don't qualify for e.i
our mercedes stephenson caught up with
canada's employment minister carla
qualtro to find out how the package will
help canadians stay afloat
mercedes robin much of the focus in
ottawa this week was on the government's
latest covid19 relief package
bill c4 it cleared both the house and
the senate and it replaces the canada
emergency response benefit
or serb the bill expands the employment
insurance system
and creates new benefits for workers who
can't go to work
because of covet 19. at one point seven
and a half
million canadians were receiving the
serb and canada's employment minister
told me there's a chance we could see
similar numbers of canadians out of work
with this second wave
here's what she had to say we know that
it's possible
that for a full economic shutdown that
we could get there we're not expecting
to get there as i said we think that we
can more tactically approach the
economic impact this
go-round but we need to be ready and we
needed our benefit system to be ready to
pivot at any time
to the reality of a lot of people being
back off of work
the conservatives say they won't support
the government's speech from the throne
but they also didn't want to get in the
way
of support they say canadians needed
that were included in that benefits bill
that has
now passed that said while they might
agree with what's in the bill
they didn't like the way the government
handled it fast tracking it through
parliament without much debate
it really is troubling to see how
trudeau continually
holds back parliament shuts down
parliament and then
is forced to because of his own actions
to ram through
legislation that is spending billions of
dollars with virtually no oversight
and it really goes to what has been a
habit of trudeau and that is
disrespecting democracy
and parliament and i i think we're
seeing him using this pandemic
to his own political advantage also on
the show we'll get the latest from
washington d.c where
u.s president donald trump and the first
lady remain in isolation
after testing positive for kovit 19. the
american election
is now just about a month away we'll
have all that and more
on the west block robin all right thanks
for that mercedes
thousands of people gathered in montreal
today to demand justice for joyce
eshequan
supporters held a peaceful march in the
city the quebec government has promised
an inquiry
into the indigenous woman's care at a
hospital eshequan recorded herself while
she was visibly distressed
and calling for help staff at the
hospital were caught on tape
taunting her with insulting remarks
shortly before she died
a nurse and an orderly have since been
fired
police in nova scotia are investigating
a hate crime
after a sign directing visitors to the
headstone of viola desmond
a canadian civil rights pioneer was
vandalized
the sign in camp hill cemetery was
marked with three
highly offensive racial slurs but they
have since been removed
in 1946 desmond was arrested for
refusing to leave a whites-only section
of a movie theater
it's one of the most high-profile cases
of racial discrimination
in canadian history coming up nearly 24
people are missing in france and italy
as storm alex pounds europe
venice felt the brunt of what's known as
storm alex
the low-lying city is particularly
vulnerable to this kind of weather
newly installed flood barriers were put
to the test and have
appeared to held back high tides earlier
france was hit with the system's fierce
winds and torrential rain
nearly 500 millimeters of rain fell in
just 12 hours near nice
france usually gets about 600
millimeters of rain
all year the mayor of knees says this is
the worst flooding
in a century millions of people living
in
and around the spanish capital are under
another strict lockdown
as cases surge madrid has become
europe's biggest hot spot
and to deal with the spiking cases
spain's government has imposed
two weeks of new restrictions among the
new rules
restaurants must stop serving food and
drinks after 10 pm
and no one is allowed to travel in and
out of the city
unless it's absolutely necessary
tighter restrictions have also been
imposed in the u.k
where cases are rising fast in northern
england it's now illegal to meet people
indoors from other households the new
rules went into action
as hundreds of university students in
the city of newcastle
tested positive for coven 19.
still ahead an ontario father's
determination to get help for his son
who has a rare disease
months ahead of their son's third
birthday an ontario couple is determined
to get him a life saving gift
the young boy has a rare disease with no
cure
it could leave him paralyzed by the age
of 10. treatment costs millions and the
pandemic halt of the family's
fundraising plan
but as karen lieberman explains nothing
can stop their perseverance
these can be isolating times for anyone
let alone the family of a child with an
ultra rare disease
michael piravalakis is the only child in
canada
with [ __ ] paraplegia type 50 spg
50 for short tolbert has been the
hardest point in my entire life right we
got
i'm working my wife is not working
anymore we have you know
we're worried about our bills worried
about how we're going to pay for
the future let's go keep going we first
met him at 18 months shortly after he
was diagnosed with a neurodegenerative
disease
that will rob him of all functions one
by one
i stopped praying for a while and i was
like you know why would they do this to
him why would he have this disease there
was no hope
no hope in a race against time the
toronto family decided to crowdfund a
cure
researchers believe gene therapy has the
potential to halt the progression of spg
50 and even reverse some of the damage
but there are no guarantees for the 60
or so people believed to have the
disease worldwide
even so michael's family and others
believe this is their only
shot as nobody has ever been treated
this way for the disease
before the covid19 pandemic has impacted
everyone in some way
shape or form and michael is no
exception his therapies were halted
and the fundraising to help save him put
on hold
so far more than one and a half million
dollars of a three million dollar goal
has been raised
that's just to get the initial clinical
trial ready for michael and up to 10
others in about a year
the family anticipates they will need
more financial help down the line
but they're only fundraising now for
their immediate needs
i think if koba didn't happen we would
have raised 2 million dollars this year
for the funding
for months from home they watched
michael's disease progress
you see that he's more in his tippy toes
rather than on his feet because the
spasticity is kicking in the paralysis
is kicking in and that's related to
being in quarantine for six months with
no therapy
so terry decided despite the pandemic
his son
must be saved so i started training and
i thought maybe i could get from here to
ottawa and we decided that we're going
to see if we can meet mr trudeau
a 400 kilometer bike ride from pickering
ontario to the nation's capital
with the goal of meeting the prime
minister and urging him to contribute to
the fundraising efforts
it's a scary thought to say that you're
so close
and just because of money you can't get
your kid treated
the journey is a costly one both
emotionally
and financially but at the heart of it
michael
a child whose future hangs in the
balance karen lieberman
global news toronto
the green party pioneer up next
elizabeth may's
impact on canada's political landscape
the green party of canada will have a
new leader thousands of members are
voting today for one of eight candidates
vying for the top job
the winner will succeed the woman who
has been the face of the party
for more than a decade eric sorensen has
a look back at the long career
of elizabeth may i organized an
environment club in my high school
long before she discovered politics
elizabeth may found the cause that would
shape her life
protecting the environment in the 70s
she organized against pesticide spraying
in her home of cape breton
in the 80s the environmental lawyer
worked on canada's earliest
climate policies on acid rain and ozone
depletion
in the government of brian mulroney
there was no doubt in my mind nor theirs
that we had to act on the climate crisis
she became a national public figure
founded the sierra club
and championed environmental awareness
to protest the infamous tar pons in cape
breton she once undertook a hunger
strike on parliament hill it was a
personal decision
that as an act of desperation soon she
would take the fight for the environment
inside the halls of parliament first by
winning the leadership of the small
often ignored green party
[Applause]
elizabeth was never in politics for
politics she always wanted to make the
world a better place particularly by
solving our serious environmental
problems
and i think she realized when the green
party leadership came open
that that was a vehicle to help her do
the right thing failing to win a seat in
her first attempt
may finally found fertile soil for a
green politician
on vancouver island and that was an
historic turning point in canadian
politics
i stand here today as the first elected
green member of parliament in canadian
history
may brought her fight to parliament and
fought her way into the national debates
you just sweep it across the table don't
you an important victory for women
and for the issue she put at the center
of canada's political discourse
she has faced controversies the views of
some green members
at a times her own comments to be
humiliated like the rest of us schmucks
but may spearheaded legislation on lyme
disease
and a ban on whales in captivity and has
worked across party lines to find
common purpose she believes she has more
climate allies in parliament today than
when she first arrived
and her message of clean green energy
only resonates more
as the planet warms it's pretty basic
that
we have a future that is not connected
to threatening our children's lives
that's so fundamental and i think most
canadians understand that
even though we're not quite ready for
that change yet she kind of speaks to
the part of us that knows this is the
right thing to do
it's the right thing to tackle climate
change may
is stepping away from the leadership but
has prepared the next generation of
climate fighters
like new mp jennica atwin she's been so
inspiring for any of us who have
you know wanted to see someone take
bolder steps for climate action it paves
the way also for other female
politicians
which we know we need more voices of
women in the house
and so she's just she's been a gift to
us
elizabeth may will still be in
parliament with a simple ethic
i'm a worker and a simple message that
she's not done yet
i just put my head down and keep on
going
eric sorenson global news and that is
global national for this saturday
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
green lake in whistler bc
we'd love to see your corner of this
country so send us your photos
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow good night
you